[Musique]
merci moi aussi j'ai l'espoir mais cette
fois ci c'est l'histoire d'un garçon
d'un adolescent de 14 ans qui va faire
une rencontre merveilleuse dans la cour
de récréation de son collège et cette
rencontre merveilleuse c'est avec eux
une conseillère d'orientation métier en
voie d'extinction malheureusement en
raison
vous connaissez certainement les
formules maîtrise des finances publiques
assainissement des finances publiques
critères de convergence du traité de
maastricht pacte de stabilité et de
croissance du traité d'amsterdam et
cette rencontre merveilleuse est une
histoire qui peut être comparé à un
spécialiste qui va enlever l'enveloppent
qu'il ya autour de cette pierre
précieuse qu'est le diamant parce que ce
petit garçon est persuadé qu'à l'issue
de la classe de troisième il doit
prendre le chemin du lycée
d'enseignement professionnel qu'on
appelle couramment le l'aip et cette
conseillère d'orientation va le
convaincre qu'il a les résultats
nécessaires pour aller en seconde dite
normale
chemin faisant cet adolescent ce garçon
va faire une autre rencontre avec un
professeur de philosophie qui répond au
doux prénom de raul cyril et qui lui
apprendra le piège de l'assimilation le
piège de l'aliénation le piège de
l'autoflagellation le piège de
l'assimilation c'est dire que je suis
et que je ne suis pas gaulois le
piège de l'aliénation
c'est dire que la guadeloupe n'est pas
simplement départements d'outre-mer une
région d'outre-mer une région ultra
périphérique de l'union européenne mais
que la guadeloupe est aussi un pays
français d'amérique et que ouaddou
pinsons des américains comme des
colombes
1 les guyanais les salvadoriens les
nicaraguayens le piège de
l'autoflagellation c'est croire que nous
avons un talent nous et que nous ne
sommes pas moins que les autres et le
petit garçon il va grandir et il
découvrira avec sidération
stupeur et voire même avec une certaine
colère que lorsque sont payés présenté
dans la littérature officielle que ce
pays la guadeloupe est présenté avec des
handicaps structurels
alors il se rebelle tout en restant
citoyens et il se dit que aux handicaps
structurels
il n'ya de richesse que d'hommes cette
belle formule de jean beaudin au
handicap géographique
il dira mais l'oeuvre de l'univers y est
parfaite au handicap dit à la taille du
grac le petit peut être aussi grand
voyons le rwanda pays émergents voyant
singapour et au handicap phénotypiques
il répondra que bien entendu la beauté
procède d'une appréciation subjective
cette histoire de ce petit garçon c'est
enlever progressivement la gang qui lie
à autour de nous pour nous convaincre
que nous sommes tous des diamants et
appliquée à l'échelle collective
ce serait de dire que la guadeloupe il
faudrait la vivre aussi pleinement comme
pays et il y à cette métaphore de la
vaisselle pour expliquer ce que les
technocrates appelle l'état minimal
l'état gendarme l'état agile la
métaphore de la vaisselle c'est que
l'état un moment donné faisait la
vaisselle à notre place dans un deuxième
temps il nous a dit faites la vaisselle
et je vous fournis le liquide vaisselle
et la paille de fer
chez nous on dirait le jex dans un
troisième temps
il nous dit et c'est ce temps là faites
votre vaisselle et je ne vous fournit
plus le liquide vaisselle et le jex au
travers de cette histoire
enlevez la gang qui a autour de notre
pays de guadeloupe c est conscient que
c'est un diamant que nous devons compter
d'abord sur nos propres forces
et puis finir par cette belle phrase du
philosophe emmanuel compte cultiver la
tendresse entre nous cultiver l'amour
qui est la synthèse de l'amitié dû
respect
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]